forcée si tu sors le deuxième concert
tour maintenant de rage c'est mieux pour
prendre place et croise une adaptation
ses marques et natation jérôme souligné
c'est une adaptation de quoi exactement
je me suis voir l'allemagne l'a fait
état qui s'applique et michelin stade ce
qui vous dire qui veut dire sur les
questions congrégation compte et que je
comprends pas
tu rentres chez toi sois qu'est ce qui
te ferait le plus peur de voir mc enroe
leconte ou lendl six mois celui qui
ferait il peur mcenroe
est-ce que tu serais prêt à mourir là
comme ça maintenant sur le champ c'est à
dire pourquoi donc est plus jamais le
salut dans l'affairé de tous les
africains puissent manger à leur faim
pendant des siècles jusqu'à données tels
ces questions a juste pourquoi pas ce
que je dis c'est tout ce que j'ai donné
la vie parce qu'on peut poser
on est tous nés
le sarthois
alors je pose des questions alors je
serai prête à mourir pour que plus
jamais de famine en afrique
déterminé et gina jean crépu la question
qu'est ce tu préfères fr poursuivi pour
une météo su préserver j'ai pas moi
cette passion des vieilles dames et pour
leur piquer leur argent dans leur sac
quand elle sort de la lafa ce qu'ils ont
touché la retraite
première solution j'étais quand la place
pigalle sandton
tu prends le pognon leur sac ou alors tu
te prennes les yeux à monte-carlo
marbella avec moi je crois que j'ai
créée dans les années
certaines choses sacrées ou légers je ne
tiens pas les lieux oui là je préférais
quand même le secteur des questions
c'est moi qui suis un mec que tu as
dehors absolument envie de faire l'amour
à craquer problème les trois solutions
la première solution il ya le hockey
il ya des choses l'italie soviétique
vraiment avant cette deuxième solution
une troisième solution il est très
pervers entre cochons qu'est ce que tu
préfères qu'est ce que c'est qu'une
chaîne ren moi alors je vais vous les
mecs qui parlent sans arrêt ou les
cochons lapins de cochonneries à sa
lettre ce beau coin
prenez les choses qui parlent bien
rigolé quand tu es au pôle nord perdu
dans la glace
il conjugue gelagri à la plongée lui
pour survire tu ne peux que le manger
plus
quand des partis qui commençait pas
quelle partie du corps qui veut refaire
les joints la cuisse le bras levante
j'ai quelqu'un que j'aime il est mort
chez les banquiers qu'est ce que tu veux
si c'est la seule façon pour y survivre
à toi qu'est-ce que tu ferais d'autres
films ouattara sinon je rattrape oui oui
oui enfin que tu commences
c'est pas
le droit la joue
tout s'éclaire dernière question tu vas
quatre ans dans un vaisseau spatial
quatre ans je peux faire partir les
catherine lara bernard tapie yannick
noah
j'ai pas répond
ça s'arrête
oui